[Música]
a
pero también participa en la carrera de
ensayos por la vacuna contra el kobe y
19 en este país se proveerán candidatas
entre que la que destacan astrazéneca y
la universidad de oxford inglaterra
johnson johnson de eeuu el imperial
college london del reino unido- your
back de alemania así como si novak
cansino biologics y sino farc de china
precisamente sino farc es la primera en
iniciar sus pruebas de fase 3 en unos 6
mil voluntarios el estudio está bajo la
supervisión de la universidad peruana
cayetano heredia y la universidad
nacional mayor de san marcos los
voluntarios tienen entre 18 y 50 años
están ha sido un entusiasmo por
participar en el experimento que a la
hora de haber sido lanzado en línea la
inscripción los primeros 3.000 cupos
fueron copados las autoridades buscan
probar que esta candidata vacuna sea
segura y efectiva por eso se dispuesto
que al azar 2.000 participantes reciban
cepas de buján otros dos mil cepas de
beijing y el resto placebos
el estudio durará 16 meses en caso las
dosis produzcan algún efecto adverso los
participantes dispondrán de un seguro
por hasta 500 mil dólares
[Música]
el primer lote de vacunas rusas para
ensayos clínicos llegarán este mes de
septiembre a venezuela según lo dio a
conocer el presidente nicolás maduro el
mandatario ha asegurado que su gobierno
firmó documentos de confidencialidad
para iniciar las pruebas de la vacuna
sputnik 5 con los venezolanos por los
momentos ya maduro ha solicitado
públicamente 500 ciudadanos voluntarios
para que permitan aplicarse la una vez
los rusos la hagan llegar al país sin
embargo el número de voluntarios
venezolanos podrían ser más ya que el
jefe de estado sugirió recientemente que
los 14 mil 400 candidatos inscritos para
participar en las próximas elecciones
parlamentarias el 6 de diciembre
deberían ponerse la vacuna rusa antes de
comenzar la campaña electoral maduro ya
ha pedido a la vicepresidenta y ministra
de finanzas del cis rodríguez que se
reúna con el consejo nacional electoral
para ver si es posible llevar a cabo su
idea
[Música]
en los últimos meses colombia también ha
estado negociando para tener la vacuna
contra el kobe 19 en su territorio en un
primer momento el ministerio de
exteriores participó el 22 de julio
junto a otros estados latinoamericanos
en una reunión con su contraparte china
el canciller wang y ofreció un préstamo
de mil millones de dólares para que los
países latinoamericanos pudiesen acceder
a la vacuna china la propuesta no
prosperó y finalmente el 26 de agosto el
instituto nacional de vigilancia de
medicamentos y alimentos de colombia
aprobó el ensayo clínico de la vacuna a
26 cop 2s desarrollada por la compañía
farmacéutica johnson and johnson de
hecho se espera que en este mes de
septiembre comiencen las pruebas de la
fase 3 en el país además colombia
participa en la coalición mundial
kóvacs un mecanismo diseñado para
garantizar un acceso rápido justo y
equitativo a las vacunas de kobe 19 en
todo el mundo este mecanismo ha
garantizado vacunas para 10 millones de
colombianos
[Música]